ukrainische präsident selen ski und
heute gibt es schon eine aktuelle stunde
am nachmittag zur lage in der ukraine
und jetzt starten wir gleich mit der
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
aber wir hören erst mal die bundestags
vizepräsidentin katrin göring eckardt
einen guten tag liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die sitzung ist eröffnet
und bevor wir zu den dingen unserer
tagesordnung kommen will ich von hier
aus sehr herzlich die präsidentin des
bundestages
andere präsidiumsmitglieder grüßen die
erkrankt sind aber auch eine ganze reihe
von kolleginnen und kollegen aus dem
parlament die erkrankt sind ich wünsche
allen gute besserung sie werden
sie werden in dieser woche mit petra pau
und mir vorliebnehmen müssen immer im
wechsel und wir freuen uns darauf das
machen zu können und freuen uns auch
wenn sie bei allen zwischen fragen und
bemerkungen die sie im kopf haben noch
mal überlegen wie sehr sie die heute im
parlament und morgen im parlament und
übermorgen im parlament vortragen müssen
aber das ist natürlich nur eine
herzliche bitte dass wir eine strafe
sitzungsleitung hinbekommen damit wir
das auch gut bewältigen so jetzt kommen
wir zur sitzung heute
und ich habe ihnen eine ganze reihe von
dingen mitzuteilen bevor wir in die
tagesordnung eintreten mit wirkung zum
14 märz hat die präsidentinnen die
allgemeinverfügung zu corona
schutzmaßnahmen im deutschen bundestag
geändert für das plenum bedeutet das
folgendes für den zutritt zu
plenarsitzungen gilt fortan wieder eine
3g regel die dreijährige bedeutet dass
zurzeit zudem plenarsitzungen
ausschließlich diejenigen personen
erhalten die vollständig gegen das
sachbuch 2 virus geimpft von einer krone
erkrankung genesen oder aktuell negativ
getestet sind diese 3g status ist nach
maßgabe der allgemeinverfügung als
zutrittsberechtigung zum plenarsaal
sowie zur ost und west lobby
einschließlich der abgeordneten lobby
nachzuweisen der 4.2 massen pflicht für
die plenarsitzung gilt wie zuvor danach
ist die ft2 maske auch am platz zu
tragen ausnahmen sind allein für die
amtierenden präsidentin präsidenten
sowie für die rednerinnen und redner am
redepult und an den saal mikrofon
zugelassen unverändert sind auch die
regelungen der allgemeinverfügung über
befreiungen von der masken pflicht
geblieben wir kommen jetzt zur
abstimmung über die gemäß der
allgemeinverfügung im plenarsaal
geltende dreijährige als teil unserer
parlamentarischen ordnung wer stimmt
dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
herzlichen dank dann sind diese
regelungen teil unserer
parlamentarischen ordnung zugestimmt
haben die fraktionen von spd cdu/csu
bündnis 90 die grünen fdp und die linke
die fdp fraktion hat sich teilweise
enthalten und teilweise dagegen gestimmt
wir kommen jetzt zur tagesordnung für
die heutige zwanzigster die morgige 21
und die 22 sitzung am freitag konnten
zwischen den fraktionen keine
tagesordnung verabredet werden die
fraktion der afg hat dem vorschlag der
anderen fraktionen widersprochen die
präsidentin hat daher den bundestag mit
der vorgeschlagenen tagesordnung
einberufen nach § 21 absatz 3 der
geschäftsordnung ist für die genehmigung
der tagesordnung ein plenar- beschluss
erforderlich
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
die noch zu beschließende tagesordnung
um die in der zusatzpunkten liste
aufgeführten punkte zu erweitern von der
frist für den beginn der beratungen soll
soweit erforderlich abgewichen werden
die tagesordnungspunkte 5 16 und 20
werden abgesetzt im anschluss an die
fragestunde findet heute auch verlangen
der fraktion der spd bündnis 90/die
grünen und fdp eine aktuelle stunde
statt das thema lautet lage in der
ukraine angesichts des
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
russlands und die auswirkungen auf
deutschland und europa morgen gibt es
auch verlangen der fraktion der cdu/csu
eine aktuelle stunde die nach
tagesordnungspunkt 10 aufgerufen wird
mit dem titel lage der ukrainischen
flüchtlinge versorgung registrierung und
verteilung organisieren teilhabe
sicherstellen frauen und kinder
besonders schützen damit kommen wir
jetzt zur feststellung der tagesordnung
der 21 20 und 22 sitzung mit den
genannten änderungen und ergänzungen wer
stimmt dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
gibt's enthaltungen
das war mir jetzt nicht ganz klar wie
das in der unionsfraktion gehandhabt
worden ist auf jeden fall kann ich
festhalten das sieht die tagesordnung so
beschlossen ist zugestimmt haben die
fraktionen der koalition und der linken
dagegen gestimmt hat die fraktionen der
kfd und bei der fraktionen der union gab
es sowohl zustimmung als auch ablehnung
als auch enthaltung
bitte
sind dafür sie haben zugestimmt im okay
dann haben nur einige ihrer hand nach
oben gehalten und dann gibt es eine
zustimmung der unionsfraktion herzlichen
dank dafür ich
rufe auf die tagesordnungspunkte
11 c sowie zusatzpunkt 1 und 2 erste
beratung des von den fraktionen der spd
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
eingebrachten gesetz der gesetzentwürfe
zur änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und andere
damit sind jemand ein tagesordnungspunkt
nach dem doch einiges einleiten zur
sitzungswoche zu sagen war und auch
wichtiges jahr habe es gehört das
bundestagspräsidium ist etwas ausgedünnt
es gibt corona bedingte ausfälle bärbel
bas beispielsweise die
bundestagspräsidentin die hatte
mitgeteilt dass sie an corona erkrankt
ist auch wolfgang kubicki von der fdp
der bundestags-vizepräsident und aydan
özoguz jetzt kommen wir aber zum ersten
punkt in dieser woche änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes am 20 märz
sollen die meisten kroner maßnahmen
wegfallen wir hören für die
bundesregierung als erste rednerin die
parlamentarische staatssekretärin
kirchenkrise
beraten heute neben dem
infektionsschutzgesetz auch das
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetz die
verlängerung des sozialdienstleister
einsatz gesetzes und weiterer regelung
und hinter diesem langen namen verbirgt
sich ein sehr sinnvolles instrument mit
dem es uns gelungen ist die soziale
infrastruktur während der korona
pandemie arbeitsfähig zu halten und weil
die pandemie noch nicht vorbei ist und
weil wir jetzt und auch noch nach der
pandemie gute wirksame bürgernah
angebote brauchen deswegen verlängern
wir diesen schutzschirm
denn viele soziale dienstleister und
einrichtungen konnten ihre wichtige
arbeit während der pandemie nicht so und
nicht dort leisten wie und wo sie es
gewohnt waren und davon betroffen ist
das gesamte spektrum der sozialen arbeit
zb die werkstätten für menschen mit
behinderung die versorgungs und
rehabilitationseinrichtungen die
einrichtung der arbeitsförderung und die
anbieter von sprachkursen besonders
betroffen sind aber die
wohlfahrtsverbände denn diese denn sie
dürfen als gemeinnützige träger anders
als kommerzielle anbieter kaum risiko
rücklagen bilden und können oftmals
keine kredite aufnehmen wir sichern mit
diesem sozialdienstleister einsatz
gesetzt ihre wichtige arbeit und sorgen
dafür dass ihre angebote auf die unsere
gesellschaft angewiesen ist auch in
zukunft bestehen ohne diese
gesetzesänderung die wir heute
einbringen würde dieser schutzschirm am
samstag nicht mehr existieren und
angesichts der hohen infektionszahlen
ist es wahrscheinlich dass es weiterhin
maßnahmen nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz geben wird die
die angebote der sozialen dienstleister
beeinträchtigten könnten und dazu zählen
ganz besonders abstands gebote und
hygiene konzepte in einrichtung und
genau für diesen fall ist es eben
erforderlich dass die soziale
infrastruktur weiter gesichert wird
wenn aber keine maßnahmen nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz erlassen werden
dann greift einfach die verlängerung
dieses gesetzes nicht ich will zwei mal
danke sagen zum ersten ein großes
dankeschön an alle die die in der
pandemie die arbeit am laufen gehalten
haben die menschen zum beispiel statt in
einer einrichtung oder einer schule zu
hause betreut haben die sich um kinder
und jugendliche um ältere menschen
gekümmert haben die sprachkurse für
geflüchtete auf digitale angebote
umgestellt haben und die neue wege der
arbeitsmarkt qualifizierung in der
bildungsarbeit gefunden haben das war
auch ein digitalisierungs schub für die
soziale arbeit und ein dankeschön an die
koalitionsfraktionen die in einem
zügigen gesetzesverfahren in dieser
woche parallel zum
infektionsschutzgesetz diesen
gesetzentwurf einbringen und noch einige
weitere wichtige regelungen mit
einbeziehen die unser gesundheitssystem
und den betrieblichen infektionsschutz
sichern im gesundheitsbereich führen wir
die regelung zur kinder krankentagen und
zum entschädigungsanspruch bei pandemie
bedingtem kinderbetreuungs ausfall fort
und sichern die vorsorge und reha
einrichtungen ab liebe kolleginnen
kollegen alle diese maßnahmen gelten in
diesem vorschlag bis zum 23 september
und ich hoffe sehr dass wir dann einen
schritt weiter sind mit der pandemie und
einen schritt weiter sind mit dem impfen
denn das impfen ist der einzige weg raus
aus dieser pandemie
sie beschuldigen die verlängern einige
basis regelungen des betrieblichen
infektionsschutz die aha + l regeln
tests können weiter angeboten werden und
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern soll
ermöglicht werden sich impfen zu lassen
ich möchte betonen dass es gerade die
maßnahmen des betrieblichen
infektionsschutz es waren die die
ausbreitung des corona virus in den
betrieben eingedenk haben eingedämmt
haben und die dafür gesorgt haben die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer zu
schützen und unsere wirtschaft aufrecht
zu erhalten betriebe müssen
betriebe müssen weiter
gefährdungsbeurteilung machen und
hygiene konzepte erstellen viele
arbeitgeber werden sich aber auch an dem
orientieren was bisher pflicht war und
werden beitrag tests und homeoffice
anbieten zum schutz ihrer
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter diese
erfahrungen mehr arbeitsschutz auch mehr
home office das ist eine der positiven
erfahrung aus der pandemie und noch ein
dankeschön an die gesundheitspolitikerin
und politiker die an das
infektionsschutzgesetz noch wichtige
regeln anhängen die auch in zukunft
dafür sorgen dass mit der kurzarbeit der
arbeitsmarkt in unserem land die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer gut
durch diese zeit kommen denn unser aller
ziel ist es jobs zu erhalten und damit
familieneinkommen zu sichern wir kümmern
uns damit auch darum die
wirtschaftlichen folgen des ukraine
krieges für den arbeitsmarkt abzusichern
meine damen und herren liebe polieren
kollegen in krisenzeiten zeigt sich ganz
besonders dass soziale sicherheit die
sicherheit einen arbeitsplatz zu haben
sich auf betreuungsangebote verlassen zu
können dass all das so existenziell
wichtig ist und mit den gesetzen die wir
heute beraten und einbringen ermöglichen
wir mehr soziale sicherheit in
schwierigen zeiten vielen dank
dass die krise so staatssekretär im
arbeitsministerium
nämlich genau wie die rechtsgrundlage
für die korona maßnahmen also das
infektionsschutzgesetz läuft auch die
geltungsdauer dauert dieses
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetzes aus
sie hat es gesagt darin ja unter anderem
sonderregelung zum kinderkrankengeld und
zuzahlung für vorsorge und reha
einrichtungen
thorsten frei von der union kolleginnen
und kollegen wir diskutieren jetzt die
einbringung der novellierung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
und da wundert es uns schon sehr dass
auch wenn es einen fraktionsantrag ist
der minister des federführenden
ministeriums karl lauterbach bei dieser
einbringung nicht hier ist und deswegen
fordern wir die zitierung des ministers
nach § 42 der geschäftsordnung
[Applaus]
gut darüber
gipse wortmeldung das ist hier so ein
bisschen unter bitteschön
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ist natürlich völlig berechtigt zu sagen
dass der gesundheitsminister anwesend
sein soll das bin ich zuerst einmal
unterstreichen ich will aber
sagen dass parallel eine
kabinettsklausur stattfindet und sich
der gesundheitsminister bereits auf dem
weg hierher befindet
so trotz dieser positiven nachricht
wollen sie abstimmen lassen herr frey
verstanden
wir lassen wir bleiben ganz ruhig
wir bleiben ganz locker und gelassen und
stimme ab
wer mehr
nein wir stimmen ab wir wollen nicht
unterbrechen dann geht hier alles noch
viel länger das wollen wir heute nicht
gewährleisten sondern wir stellen jetzt
ab und deswegen frage ich wer ist für
die zitierung des gesundheitsministers
vielen dank der ist dagegen
[Musik]
enthält sich jemand
das ist nicht der fall
herzlichen dank wir sind uns hier einig
dass eine mehrheit der kolleginnen und
kollegen der zitierung nicht zugestimmt
hat und freuen uns gleichwohl darauf
dass der gesundheitsminister bald
anwesend sein wird ich gebe das ja wort
der geschichte ordnungsantrag der
unionsfraktion der abgestimmt werden
muss denn es gibt nach der
geschäftsordnung des bundestages die
möglichkeit den antrag zu stellen dem
minister herbei zu zitieren hat hier die
ampel koalition mit mehrheit erst mal
abgelehnt das heißt es geht erstmal
weiter in der aussprache zum
infektionsschutzgesetz und anderen
vorlage mit hendrik hoppenstedt für die
unionsfraktion von über 1600 haben wir
heute einen der tage mit der höchsten
verbreitung des virus seit ausbruch der
pandemie tendenz übrigens steigend wir
müssen alleine heute
269 menschen leben betrauern die an und
mit krone den letzten 24 stunden
verstorben sind
ihre antwort auf diese schlimme lage ist
der vorliegende gesetzesentwurf und der
lässt einen einigermaßen fassungslos
zurück noch in der mpk vom 16 februar
wurde zwar beschlossen das
niedrigschwellige basisschutz maßnahmen
möglich sein sollen zum beispiel masken
pflicht in geschlossenen räumen
abstandsgebot allgemeine hygiene
vorgaben und ähnliches insbesondere auch
in schulen und kitas im gesetzesentwurf
ist davon aber keine rede mehr nur noch
in krankenhäusern und ähnlichen
einrichtungen sowie in luft und
öffentlichen personenverkehr kann die
masken pflicht angeordnet werden in
ausgewählten einrichtungen kann eine
fest testpflicht gelten und das war's
dann auch schon es wird dann immer
argumentiert dass die hotspot regelung
noch der große heilsbringer sei genau
das ist sie aber nicht und zwar aus zwei
gründen erstens
ein echte basis schutzmaßnahmen wie
masken tragen zu ermöglichen ist eine
drohende überbelastung der lokalen
krankenhäuser zwingende voraussetzung
das ist eine sehr hohe hürde und derzeit
nirgends erreichbar ihre hoffnung ganz
deutschland in einen hotspot gebiet
umzuwandeln sich die hoffnung der fdp
aber der anderen ampelkoalition ehre ist
also falsch zweiter die entscheidung
über hotspot treffen die
landesparlamente das widerspricht dem
grundsatz der gewaltenteilung bei das
klasse exekutive entscheidungen sind wie
soll denn ein landtag entscheiden wie
soll denn eine landtag jede einzelne
gemeinde und jeder einzelnen
krankenhäuser vor ort im blick haben es
müssten dann eigentlich fast täglich
landtagssitzungen stattfinden um adäquat
auf das infektionsgeschehen reagieren zu
können fazit wenn dieser text so bleibt
wird die hotspot regelung
allen gegenteiligen beteuerungen zum
trotz keine große relevanz entfalten
damit existieren praktisch keine basis
schutzmaßnahmen mehr und der von der fdp
propagierte freedom day bis dann
tatsächlich realität geworden er hat
mich einmal mehr es würde eine
zwischenfrage geben aus der fdp-fraktion
möchten sie nicht ungern von auf die
fraktion bereit aber mehr hat die fdp
die beiden koalitionspartner in
geiselhaft genommen zustimmung dazu gibt
es vermutlich in der fdp-fraktion wir
wissen es noch nicht genau meine damen
und herren es geht hier nicht um
irgendwelche politischen fehler die wir
alle mal gemacht haben und die
schlimmstenfalls steuergeld kosten es
geht hier tag um tag um circa 300
menschen die am virus sterben wir als
union können und wollen uns damit nicht
abfinden auch wenn das grundrecht auf
leben und körperliche unversehrtheit
nicht absolut gilt so hat es in unserer
rechtsordnung ein überragend hohen
stellenwert masken tragen abstandsgebot
hygienemaßnahmen beachten sollten eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein angesichts
des leides welches das virus über unsere
gesellschaft gebracht hat liebe
kolleginnen kollegen von der spd und den
grünen sie fühlen sich erkennbar unwohl
mit diesem gesetzesentwurf ihre
kurzfristigen eingereichten
änderungsanträge
helfen aber dabei nicht wirklich weiter
die verbesserungen sind marginal
so ist die ermächtigungsgrundlage für
die länder eine masken pflicht in
schulen anzuordnen
nach wie vor nicht enthalten ich zitiere
dazu herrn lauterbach wäre ja schön wenn
er da wäre er ist da wunderbar von daher
appelliere ich wirklich an alle länder
dass man hier vorgibt dass in den
schulen masken getragen werden
tatsächlich ist die maske bei der
omicron variante sehr effizient und
würde gerade in den schulen eine große
sicherheit bieten zitat ende ein mangel
an erkenntnis hersteller nicht sondern
es fehlt schlichtweg das politische
gewicht sich gegen herrn buschmann
durchzusetzen und somit zeigt dieser
gesetzesentwurf übrigens auch in seinem
verfahren der eine einzige
unverschämtheit ist gegenüber den
ländern aber auch gegenüber der
opposition die ganze zerrissenheit der
ampel für eine solche desaströse corona
politik kann die union kein
steigbügelhalter sein wir als union
lesen diesen gesetzesentwurf grund herum
ab dankeschön die unionsfraktionen hat
natürlich beobachtet dass es in der
ampelkoalition durchaus ja ein
kompromiss war dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz diese änderungen
die fdp hatte andere vorstellungen als
spd und grüne das werden wir verlauf der
aussprache sicher noch höheren
habe ich nicht nachgefragt und geben
jetzt das wort ja kollegin maria klein
was sie zum infektionsschutzgesetz und
dieser kompromiss sagt
wir haben heute tatsächlich eine
situation wo man sagen muss in einer
zeit mit höchstwerten bei den instanzen
mit höchstwerten auch im anstieg auch im
mit höchstwerten bei den gestorbenen pro
tag dass wir eine schwierige abwägung zu
vollziehen haben das sei vorweg gesagt
und vorweg sei auch gesagt dass heute
keinesfalls der tag sein kann wo wir den
tag der freiheit ausrufen wie das die
afg mit ihrem antrag macht ich finde in
dieser situation angesichts der zahlen
die wir haben auf der einen seite und
zweitens angesichts dessen was im namen
der freiheit und zur sicherung der
freiheit in der ukraine gerade passieren
muss wie sich die menschen werden wie
sie für die demokratie einstehen ist das
zynisch was sie hier machen
mit
mit dem 19 märz laufen
vorsichtsmaßnahmen schutzmaßnahmen aus
im 28 28 b die wir gemeinsam aus dem
rhein hier das des bundestages im
november aufgestellt haben mit
beteiligung der fdp mit beteiligung der
spd mit beteiligung von uns grünen sehr
schlau regelungen im übrigen die uns gut
durch die zeit geholfen haben die dazu
geführt haben dass wir selbst die delta
variante die wir in ihren auswirkungen
nicht kannten gut bewältigen kunden mit
aller belastung und das müssen wir an
dieser stelle natürlich deutlich sagen
für die krankenhäuser und für diejenigen
die dort gearbeitet haben und arbeiten
was wir da dankbar feststellen müssen so
und jetzt sind wir in einer neuen
situation bei einer neuen variante frau
kleinschneider lich müssen wir abwägen
es gibt den wunsch nach einer
zwischenfrage aus der art die fraktion
einsatz grundsätzlich ab wir müssen
abwägen wir müssen eine gute abwägung
treffen zwischen dem schutz und dem was
wir wissen an folgen aus freier als
freiheitseinschränkung passiert und da
kann ich sagen wir haben lange ringen
müssen wir haben einen kompromiss
vorliegen von minister buschmann von
minister lauterbach der uns grüne nicht
zufriedenstellt aber er ist das was
unter demokratischen bedingungen in der
ampel miteinander verabredet werden
konnten und wir werden haben den
allgemeinen masken schutz im fernverkehr
im luftverkehr wir werden als allgemeine
maß aufgaben und schutzmaßnahmen haben
in den einrichtungen für wohlhabende
menschen dass wir da sowohl eine masken
pflicht haben und eine testpflicht und
zusätzlich diese testpflicht auch in
kita und schule und den verschiedenen
einrichtungen im asyl bewerber verfahren
das ist wichtig das war uns auch wichtig
und deshalb war es nie eine alternative
keine regelung zu haben wie sich das die
fdp hätte vorstellen können und da
müssen wir sagen natürlich ist es sehr
schwer dazu zu stehen aber wir sehen
gleichzeitig diese maßnahmen diese basis
maßnahmen sind vorhanden und sie sind
auch weiterhin will
um zugleich müssen wir auch sagen es ist
absehbar das wurde heute im ausschuss
noch einmal deutlich wir werden noch
einen weiteren anstieg der zahlen sehen
wir werden vielleicht auch noch mal
nachsteuern müssen das sage ich auch
ganz gezielt in die richtung der
kolleginnen und kollegen der fdp aber es
besteht keine alternative dazu keine
regelungen zu haben sondern wenigstens
diese basismaßnahmen und von daher
plädieren wir dafür jetzt im verfahren
darf sofort zu fangen wir werden gleich
im ausschuss einige verbesserungen
gegenüber dem entwurf sehen wir werden
sehen dass es verbesserungen bei den
einrichtungen gibt der bewohner hable
betreut werden und behandelt werden wir
werden sehen verbesserungen bei den
maßnahmen rund um das hier gehende
konzept das waren uns wichtige
verbesserungen es kann sein dass wir
feststellen müssen dass reichlich
und es kann auch sein dass wir
feststellen müssen dass der gesamte
katalog dessen was wir gemeinsam hier
erarbeitet hatten im november eigentlich
der tragfähigere gewesen wären und wir
noch mal nachsteuern müssen in dem sinne
tun wir das und ich freue mich auch
darüber dass wir die regelungen zum
kinderkrankengeld fortsetzen dass wir
die regelung zum elterngeld fortsetzen
das sind wichtige und zum
kurzarbeitergeld das sind wichtige
weitere regelungen zu denen wir ganz
ganz klar uns gemeinsam verabredet haben
um die folgen für die bevölkerung
möglichst weit abzufedern und damit wir
gut in den herbst kommen aber es kann
sein dass wir nach schulen müssen in dem
sinne bitte ich um konstruktive beraten
das gesagt also bundesweit gibt es noch
einen sogenannten basisschutz basis
schutzmaßnahmen wie die massen und
pflichten flug und fernverkehr sowie
masken und test vorschriften in
altenheimen die masken pflicht die
allgemeine beispielsweise im
einzelhandel wird es nicht mehr geben
aber durch eine hotspot regelung im
gesetzentwurf ist vorgesehen dass die
bundesländer unter bestimmten
bedingungen härtere maßnahmen ergreifen
können
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen heute
am 16 märz vor genau zwei jahren ist der
erste krone lockdown von der
bundesregierung beschlossen worden kurz
danach haben große teile deutschlands in
den ersten stillstand geschickt der
einzige grund für alle maßnahmen unter
einschränkungen war immer die vermeidung
des systems das system ist eine
überlastung unseres gesundheitswesens
die gefahr bestand jedoch zu keinem
zeitpunkt das werden die nachfolgenden
zahlen verdeutlichen nach auswertung der
daten des instituts für entgeltsystem im
krankenhaus gab es in deutschen
krankenhäusern im jahr 2019
19,2 millionen abgerechnete fälle im
jahr 2020 nur noch 16,7 millionen
abgerechnete fälle und im letzten jahr
2021 noch 16,6 millionen fälle die
abgerechnet worden sind unser
gesundheitssystem hat also in jedem der
beiden vorjahre 2,5 millionen weniger
fälle als im jahr 2019 ohne krone
insofern haben wir also sogar eine
deutliche unterauslastung unsere
kapazitäten zu verzeichnen wenn also das
hauptargument für alle maßnahmen die
drohende überlastung unserer
krankenhäuser war dann muss der nachweis
einer unterauslastung zum sofortigen
ende aller maßnahmen führen
[Applaus]
und um einzel nicht zu vergessen wir
haben bis heute immer noch keine validen
daten hinsichtlich der wirksamkeit der
maßnahmen in der öffentlichen anhörung
des gesundheitsausschusses von 14
dritten zur änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
sagte der sachverständige professor
doktor hendrik strikt ich zitiere mit
einem mit einverständnis der präsidentin
einen klaren wissenschaftlichen beweis
für die wirkung von 2g oder 3g jährigen
lockt downs und ausgangssperren gibt es
bisher nicht
des weiteren konnte weder die deutsche
krankenhausgesellschaft noch der
sprecher dass die wie der sieg ist das
bei der anhörung am montag die frage
beantworten wie hoch der anteil der
patienten ist welche wegen oder nur mit
krone auf der station liegen auf der
basis solcher daten neue gesetze zu
beschließen die dann den ländern die
möglichkeit bietet wieder grundrechts
einschränkende maßnahmen zu feiern lädt
unsere fraktion ab
gerade kolleginnen kollegen nicht
zitieren mit erlaubnis der präsidentin
es gibt ein absolutes ende aller
maßnahmen und alle maßnahmen spätestens
mit dem frühlingsbeginn am 20 märz 2022
das sind die worte unseres
justizministers marco buschmann vom ende
oktober 2021 als ein ergebnis der
koalitionsverhandlungen
dass sich spd und grüne daran nicht
erinnern können oder wollen wundert mich
jetzt nicht wirklich aber die fdp
man kann nur hoffen dass ihre wähler ein
besseres gedächtnis haben und die
nächste bundestagswahl nutzen um sie
zurück ins jahr 2013 zu schicken
sehr geehrte kolleginnen kollegen die
bürger in unserem land haben die nase
voll von der seit zwei jahren
andauernden gängelei dieses nanny
staates deswegen vertrauen sie unseren
bürgern heben sie alle beschränkungen
auf und lassen sie die menschen in
deutschland wieder selbstbestimmt und
eigenverantwortlich leben ich fordere
sie auf nehmen wir unseren
justizminister beim worten lassen sie
uns alle corona maßnahmen zum
frühlingsbeginn am 20 märz beenden haben
sie den mut zur freiheit und machen sie
mit uns diesen tag zum tag der freiheit
für deutschland vielen dank
die cdu fraktion war das um die fdp
fraktion hat das auch in einen antrag
geschrieben das ende aller kohona
maßnahmen der hiermit beraten wird die
bundesländer indes haben schon in der
mehrheit angekündigt dass sie die korona
regeln bis zweiten april verlängern
wollen denn im gesetzentwurf der hier
beraten wird in dieser woche da ist eine
übergangsfrist vorgesehen also
dass zum weiteren verfahren und kreation
wir für die fdp
christina
kolleginnen und kollegen
selbstverständlich ist corona noch nicht
vorbei und leider wird uns das virus
auch noch weiter erhalten aber deswegen
und gerade deswegen müssen wir noch
lernen im alltag mit diesem virus zu
leben
und jetzt das positive dabei wir sind
nicht in derselben situation wie vor
zwei jahren wir haben wirksame
impfstoffe meine damen und herren auch
gegen omikron deswegen fordere ich immer
lassen sie sich impfen und lassen sie
sich postern wir haben antivirale
medikamente die schwere verläufe
verhindern auch das ist anders als vor
zwei jahren und wir wissen mehr über das
virus als noch vor zwei jahren
die jetzige baa2 omikron sub variante
scheint sich als vorherrschende
virusvariante im moment gerade
durchzusetzen und hat eine noch höhere
übertragbarkeit als die b1 variante
deswegen auch die hohen infektionszahlen
aber das ist uns ganz wichtig beide
virusvarianten versuch verursachen
häufig milde verläufe und wir alle
kennen doch aus unserem bekanntenkreis
die fälle doppelt geimpfte haben das
virus wussten es gar nicht haben es
durch zufall erfahren und haben milde
verläufe die infektionszahlen sind zwar
hoch aber die krankenhaus- und
intensivmedizinische behandlung hat sich
von diesen hohen infektionszahlen
weitgehend entkoppelt und zum beweis
dafür einmal ein vergleich genau heute
vor einem jahr hatten wir eine instanz
von 84 man vergisst das immer und dabei
eine hospitalisierung rate von 6,1 zum
vergleich zu heute wir haben eine
inzidenz von
1607 bei einer spezialisierung rate von
7,4 da sehen sie doch dass wir dieses
virus anders beurteilen müssen und das
zeigt
und das zeigt
dass sich das virus während der pandemie
verändert hat und deswegen müssen wir
bei mikron auch andere schlüsse und
andere maßnahmen zu lassen meine damen
und herren um noch einmal auf die
todeszahl zu kommen ich habe mir mal den
rk ii lagebericht den letzten vom
zehnten dritten vorgenommen aktuell
steigt die zahl der todesfälle leicht an
liegt aber weiterhin deutlich unter dem
niveau aller vorhergehenden wählen auch
das müssen wir bei der beurteilung
gerücht ich in meine damen und herren
und jetzt lassen sie uns doch bitte noch
mal das ziel vor augen führen dass das
ziel aller maßnahmen in der
vergangenheit und in der zukunft und das
ist es die überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern und vor
allem und ganz ganz wichtig die
vulnerable in gruppen zu schützen und
genau das machen wir jetzt mit der
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
meine damen und herren
einschränkungen sind nur dort vorgesehen
wo sie auch wirklich notwendig sind
nämlich in alten- und
pflegeeinrichtungen den krankenhäusern
in ganz wichtig in einrichtung für
menschen mit behinderung und im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr die
masken pflicht sowie weitere
einschränkungen also die allgemeine
masken pflicht und weitere
einschränkungen fallen außerhalb dieser
holen arabien gruppen weitgehend weg und
da setzen wir nach zwei jahren pandemie
endlich wieder auf die
eigenverantwortung der bürgerinnen und
bürger meine damen und herren
zwischenfrage aus der fraktion die linke
möchten sie die zu lassen aus der
fraktion die linke möchten sie die zu
dass ihr bitte
vielen vielen dank für den vortrag die
einfache frage ob die wohlhabenden club
gruppen in zukunft einkaufen gehen
können oder nicht ob sie also die masken
pflicht auch in diesen gegenden wo hohe
gruppen hin kommen dürfen können und
sollen ob sie die berücksichtigt haben
oder ob sie nicht mehr einkaufen gehen
dürfen
es gibt nämlich auch noch eine
zwischenfrage aus der unionsfraktion die
würde ich noch mitnehmen dann können sie
beides zusammen beantworten und
die redepause das wäre genau besondere
zeiten erfordern besondere maßnahmen
vielen dank frau präsidentin auch vielen
dank liebe frau aschenberg dugnus dass
die zwischenfrage zu lassen also ich in
ihre rede gefolgt ich fand das auch
teilweise sehr sehr gut was wir gesagt
haben ich würde nur interessieren ob das
die meinung der bundesregierung ist weil
wir ja bei der frage
infektionsschutzgesetz den dissens haben
dass der bundesgesundheitsminister
offensichtlich sein eigenes gesetz nicht
kennt bei der frage der hotspot regelung
sich so ein lässt das hot spots auch
ganze bundesländer umfassen könnten wenn
die zahlen steigen obwohl nicht genau
geklärt ist wieder die inzidenz werden
zu verstehen sind und der
bundesjustizminister und sein
ministerium aber sagten nein das sind
nur explizit ganz kleine lokale
bereichen deshalb würde mich
interessieren ist jetzt dass die
auffassung dass jede äußert haben die
der bundesregierung oder ist das jetzt
eher die meinung des bmj oder der fdp
vielen dank
dann würde ich zunächst den kollegen von
den linken selbstverständlich sind
masken wichtig zum schutz aber wir
wollen ja auch die masken nicht
verbieten das behaupten zwar einige aber
wir sind ja für den maßgeblich und wir
sind die verantwortung und jeder der
eben entsprechend wohlrabe list ich zum
beispiel bin 62 jahre alt und ich werde
auch ohne masken pflicht in bestimmten
bereichen und in bestimmten situationen
meine maske aufsetzen gerade einer
infektion zweimaster nämlich begonnen es
schützt und insofern schützen wir mit
diesem gesetzentwurf mit dieser änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes gerade
besonders die wohlhabenden gruppen aber
alle anderen bereiche stellen wir in die
eigenverantwortung der bürgerinnen und
bürger und das ist das was doch gerade
und zweiter bringt und wir müssen doch
die nächsten jahre mit diesem verdammten
virus leben und da müssen wir auch den
umgang damit lernen und da ist es doch
mit wie reigen mit der eigenverwaltung
eigenen verantwortung ganz besonders
wichtig also bitte tun sie nicht so als
wenn wir da irgendwas verbieten wollten
sondern werden sie doch dafür in
bestimmten situationen die maske zu
tragen das wäre doch der richtige ansatz
als hier so ein etwas zu erzählen so
jetzt komm ich zu meinem kollegen guido
sorge ich war noch gar nicht bei den hot
spots deswegen weiß ich gar nicht
wahrscheinlich hatten sich die frage auf
geschrieben und das passte hier trage so
ich werde zu den hot spot noch kommen
lieber zur sorge
und ich muss sagen der gesetzestext wenn
sie sich den mal durchlesen in ruhe und
wir hatten ihn mir heute im ausschuss
und nachher werden werden auch noch mal
beraten ist für mich klar unter welchen
voraussetzungen dann dort eben die
entsprechenden maßnahmen getroffen
werden müssen insofern sehe ich
überhaupt kein problem wir sind uns da
in der koalition sehr einig und insofern
ist es für uns klar wie das auszulegen
ist vielen dank
ein schuldiger jetzt möchte ich gerne
mal mit meiner rede weitermachen
besonders wichtig ist uns auch dass die
masken pflicht in schulen und kitas
wegfällt meine damen und herren die
kinderpsychiatrie sind überfüllt und
alle kinderärzte schlagen alarm was wir
hier mit unseren kindern machen sie
begrüßen die abschaffung der masken
pflicht in schulen und kitas und das ist
auch richtig so gestik und mimik ist für
einen jungen menschen ganz ganz wichtig
und deswegen sagen wir auch die soziale
kompetenz hängt auch daran ob man in der
schule und in der kita eine maske tragen
muss oder nicht und ich wundere mich
doch sehr über die cdu die das jetzt
gerade kritisiert hat ich kann mich
daran erinnern dass angela merkel mal
gesagt hat kinder sollen die ersten sein
die in der die von der pandemie die von
der abschaffung der maßnahmen
profitieren da höre und sehe ich jetzt
überhaupt nichts mehr bei ihm vor mich
eigentlich schon jetzt zu den hotspots
90 netz verschieden hatte ich frag jetzt
noch ein letztes mal wollen sie noch
eine zwischenfrage zu lassen aus so
unheimlich würde jetzt gern also ich hab
jetzt brauchen sie sich nicht mehr daher
den reiseleitern sowie haben die
hotspots regelungen die sind dieser
mechanismus ist sachgerecht und sinnvoll
was nicht sinnvoll ist und was nicht zu
rechtfertigen ist das aufgrund möglicher
zukunfts varianten aufgrund einer hätte
könnte argumentation einschränkungen
aufrechterhalten werden das machen zum
beispiel auch unsere europäischen
nachbarländer nicht finnland schweden
dänemark norwegen alle haben sie keine
massen pflicht mehr sie vertrauen der
eigenverantwortung der bevölkerung in
österreich großbritannien keine masken
pflichtschulen pflicht niederlande ins
ident 2650 keinem av kollegin
dass die redezeit wer jetzt zu ende die
worte ich gerade so war dabei ich finde
wir haben hier ein gutes gesetz
vorgelegt eine änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes ich freue mich
auf die weiteren beratungen hätte noch
viel zu sagen gehabt aber das mache ich
beim nächsten mal vielen dank
es ist eine hotspot regelung
gesetzentwurf vorgesehen wonach die
bundesländer unter bestimmten
bedingungen härtere maßnahmen ergreifen
können allerdings ist nicht so ganz
unstrittige was eigentlich ein hotspot
ist da gibt es unterschiedliche lesarten
gemeinde- kreis- oder ganzes bundesland
und soll eine region zum hot spot
erklärt werden dann nur wenn eine
gefährliche virusvariante auftaucht über
die überlassung der krankenhäuser und
für viele fürchten dass bietet raum für
interpretation ich weiß nicht was mich
mehr verwundern wohl verspätung von herr
lauterbach die die umgehung des
eigentlichen themas von frau krise indem
sie ein gesetz begutachtet was einfach
nur verlängert wird oder eben jetzt das
was aus der fdp gekommen ist wir haben
die höchsten instanzen seit pandemie
beginnen hunderte menschen sterben
täglich hunderttausende haben mit longo
witt zu kämpfen operationen werden immer
noch verschoben heute in bayern eine
meldung und wir wissen nicht was eine
nächste virusvariante bringt und als
reaktion gibt die regierung nun nahezu
alle regelungen ab die die instanzen
beherrschbar machen können und sie herr
lauterbach verteidigen darf die tage
noch als ihre idee bitten jedoch die
länder ihr gesetz jetzt noch nicht
umzusetzen ist doch keine ernsthafte
politik die sie hier betreiben
wir haben bereits aber es ist der erste
bereits ende letzten jahres wurden nach
mehr drei monaten drei monate im
nichtstun das gesetz innerhalb kürzester
zeit durch das parlament gepeitscht ein
fehlerhaftes gesetz inmitten der
del-tabelle wohlgemerkt dann die
änderung zu impfen genesenen status
wieder innerhalb kürzester zeit wieder
fehlerhaft wird jetzt teil
zurückgenommen nun nächstes gesetz
innerhalb einer woche obwohl der termin
ist auch nicht schon nicht unbekannt war
ergebnis wenn ich die meinung der
experten experten bei der anhörung zum
gesetz am montag mal ganz grob
zusammenfassen darf handwerklich
schlecht inhaltlich ein desaster
es gab ja
herr lauterbach zu beginn in der
bevölkerung hoffnung als die us minister
benannt wurden ich gebe zu bei mir war
die hoffnung auf den bereich der
pandemie bekämpfung beschränkt für die
meisten anderen bereiche bekämpfung ist
pflegemangel tapfer schon abschaffung
der fallpauschalen die
krankenhausfinanzierung da liefen ihre
bisherigen politischen einlassungen
wenig raum für hoffnung aber nun gehen
sie gerade in der pandemie bekämpfung
dem bereich der ist ihr steckenpferd
galt wo sie als mahner durch die
talkshow franken nach einem vierteljahr
ko sie wissen genau dass die menschen
bei dem nun folgenden flickenteppich das
restvertrauen in die pandemie bekämpfung
verlieren werden herr lauterbach
es gibt einen dreiklang um ehrlich auf
der sache rauszukommen erstens sie
beschreiben was das gesetz real bedeutet
durchseuchung und chaos als strategie
das ist die realität zweitens sie
erklären dass sie auf die erpressung der
fdp nichts erwidern konnten das würde
nämlich auch den zustand der koalition
beschreiben die partei setzt sich durch
die jetzt schon auf ihrer internetseite
die rückkehr zur normalität feiert 100
kurator täglich das ist normalität für
die fdp
drittens
die linke hat ihre arbeit gemacht wir
haben für die nächste lesung ist ja auch
schon freitag ist ja gleich einen
entschließungsantrag und einen antrag
zur pcr test erfahren weil beigelegt
beide anträge haben andere auch der
gegenwärtigen pandemische situation eine
konsequente linie entwickeln ernsthafte
verfahren und einheitliche maßnahmen je
nach instrumenten sie beziehen experten
experten ein und versuchen sie einer
langfristigen strategie um die menschen
zu schützen stimmen sie dem einfach zu
alles andere ich komme zum schluss ist
unehrlich und lässt die menschen
verwirrt und selbstredend irgendwann
auch erkrankt zurück freedom day werden
ansonsten die viren und nicht die
menschen feiern vielen vielen dank
[Applaus]
beispiel das spricht für die spd
fraktion
du siehst die rechtspolitische
sprecherin der sozialdemokraten
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kollegen der demokratischen fraktion mit
dem 19 märz enden die aktuellen corona
maßnahmen das bedeutet wir müssen als
gesetzgeber tätig werden und wir mussten
eine einigung erzielen andernfalls würde
ab sonntag dem virus tür und tor
geöffnet werden mit all seinen
konsequenzen für unsere bürgerinnen und
bürger nach zwei jahren pandemie gibt
bekämpfung ist das nicht unser ziel
durch die zeitliche durch die zeitliche
begrenzung der maßnahmen müssen wir
konstant evaluieren ganz klares ergebnis
die pandemie ist nicht vorbei es wurde
viel drauf eingegangen ganz im gegenteil
wir brauchen maßnahmen zum schutz der
bürgerinnen und bürger
auch wenn die omikron variante häufig
einen milderen verlauf bedeutet steigen
die infektionszahlen und die
ansteckungszahlen wir haben heute die
höchste instanz in europa es werden mehr
menschen in krankenhäuser eingeliefert
und pro tag sterben 200 bis 300 menschen
aufgrund von der korona infektion daran
können wir uns und daran werden wir uns
nicht gewöhnen hier müssen wir handeln
wir handeln denn das auslaufen ist keine
option und wenn sie sagen die stimmen
diesen wenn sie sagen sie stimmen diesen
gesetzesentwurf nicht zu dann stimmen
sie quasi am auslaufen der verlängerung
zu
das vorliegen das vorliegende gesetz das
vorliegende gesetz ist ein radler
kompromiss auf eine voraussichtliche
verbesserung der lage im sommer sollen
wir vorbereitet sein aber wir wollen uns
und den ländern auch zugleich die
möglichkeit geben zu handeln und wir
haben die zusage der fdp dass
gegebenenfalls nachgesteuert werden kann
ich kann ihnen sagen wir nehmen diese
zusage sehr sehr ernst
in einzelnen
im einzelnen bezieht sich das gesetz
jetzt auf basis schutzmaßnahmen und auf
hotspots regelungen die die länder
lassen können denn der basisschutz nach
paragraf 28 absatz 7 verfolgt das ziel
bundebele gruppen in einrichtungen
krankenhäusern arztpraxen und
pflegeeinrichtungen durch masken und
tests zu schützen in anderen sensiblen
einrichtungen muss weiter gibt's oder
kann weiter getestet werden und masken
werden im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr weiter zu tragen
seien die hotspot regelung nach paragraf
28 absatz 8 infektionsschutzgesetz gibt
den ländern die möglichkeit auf die
ausbreitung zu reagieren denn wir müssen
das pandemie geschehen unter kontrolle
halten
mit beschluss mit beschluss der
landesparlamente und dies ist möglich
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der cdu
csu fraktion kann auch die mars kann auf
die infektionen reagiert werden und
können bewährte maßnahmen erlassen
werden hierbei ist juristisch ganz ganz
klar definiert dass eine
gebietskörperschaft auch ein bundesland
sein kann das doch dass
die allgemeine meistens nicht ist dann
weiter möglich in den hotspots die
pflicht zur vorlage von im chinesen und
test nachweisen und die einführung von
hygiene konzepten ja die hoffnung
ist an enge ist ein engel
voraussetzungen gebunden wie die erhöhte
partie genäht oder die überlastung von
krankenhaus
ich habe jetzt zwei wünsche nach
zwischenfragen einer aus der
unionsfraktion und eine aus der fraktion
die linke möchten sie eine davon zu
lassen beide wie sie mögen ich leider
sind dann
bitte schön
ja
freilich werde ich auch ihren
ausführungen ja bisher sehr aufmerksam
zugehört auch ihre ausführungen warum
sie meinen das jetzt hier noch einen
guten kompromiss schließen wenn ich es
richtig in erinnerung habe sind sie ja
auch eine der kolleginnen und kollegen
hier im deutschen bundestag die sich für
eine allgemeine zügige impfpflicht
aussprechen und ich habe jetzt eine ganz
konkrete frage wie können sie es
eigentlich vertreten frau redet dass sie
einer wohlhabenden personen
ab ersten april wenn die länder die
übergangsvorschrift in anspruch nehmen
zumuten dass sie quasi
ungeschützt beim einkaufen der gefahr
ausgesetzt wird dass sie sich den corona
virus einfängt weil sie die masken
pflicht im öffentlichen bereich wie dem
einkaufen mit dieser regelung außer
kraft setzen und diese wollen die person
das kann zum beispiel ein schwer kranker
mensch sein mit einem geschwächten
immunsystem
schutzlos ausliefern der kann nur noch
sich selbst mit der maske schützen ist
seine gegenüber aber hilflos
ausgeliefert wenn er keine maske trägt
und gleichzeitig treten sie für eine
impfpflicht ein die nachweislich nur
einen eigenschutz und nur noch einen
geringen fremdschutz erbringt wie kann
man einer solchen regelungen zu stimmen
und nicht eine verantwortungslose
regelung hier vorlegen das können sie ja
bei der impfpflicht auch gleich wie wir
das auch gleich noch die andere frage
wer hatte die frau vogel ich habe es
nicht gesehen leider frau
vielen dank
sie haben gerade über die hotspot
regelung gesprochen die die
landesparlamente in kraft setzen können
unter bestimmten bedingungen wirklich
aus nrw nrw es bekanntermaßen das
bevölkerungsreichste bundesland mit über
50 selbstständigen gebietskörperschaften
also landkreisen und städten und wir
haben ein parlament das durchaus fleißig
ist aber längst nicht so häufig tag wie
der deutsche bundestag zum beispiel
erwarten sie tatsächlich von ihren
kolleginnen und kollegen der spd
fraktion im landtag von
nordrhein-westfalen dass sie das
infektionsgeschehen in allen 54 oder 55
landkreisen und städten in nrw so im
blick behalten können dass sie erkennen
können wenn sich irgendwo wenn sich
irgendwo eine dynamik ausbreitet die man
durch diese hotspot regelung
bekämpfen müsste und müssten wir dich
eigentlich unser gesamtes land zum
hotspot erklären mit einer inzidenz von
über 1600 steigenden infektionszahlen
steigenden todeszahlen steigenden
hospitalisierung 's raten und einer
situation oder rk ii monitor quasi jede
woche eine neue farbe dazu bekommen muss
weil die alten farben nicht ausreichend
um tatsächlich die instanzen dort zu
stellen
so jetzt zur antwort feuchte vielen
vielen dank für die beiden fragen ich
möchte gerne auf die zuletzt gestellte
frage zuerst
antworten sie am das derzeitige pandemie
geschehen nicht nur in nrw seien ja auch
ein ganz deutschland geschildert durch
am anfang darauf eingegangen bin ich
möchte ihnen sagen dass gerade die
eng voraussetzung nach der sicht von mir
das muster in definiert werden durch die
landtage natürlich auch tatsächlich
eingetreten sind dass wir sehr viele hot
spots nach dieser neuen regelung zur
zeit in deutschland aufgrund der hohen
infektionszahlen in der schwierigkeiten
in den krankenhäusern auch haben denn
wir
haben
wir wir haben die krankenhäuser nicht im
normalbetrieb wir haben enge
personaldecke in den krankenhäusern und
auch durch ansteckung in gefahr
kapazitätsgrenzen definieren sich nicht
nur dadurch wie viele patienten in den
krankenhäusern sind auch sondern auch
dass die gewährleistung der versorgung
sichergestellt sein muss die
hospitalisierung raten steigen und ein
abflauen der institute zahlen ist
zurzeit nicht in sicht es ist eine
notlage und das ist auch nach der sicht
meiner fraktion die definition eines
hotspots die den ländern die möglichkeit
gibt zu handeln und auf die frage ob
ihre frage bezüglich auf ihre frage
bezüglich
des überblicks eines landesparlamentes
in den einzelnen kreisen ich weiß dass
mein ministerpräsident in brandenburg
wöchentlich telefonkonferenzen mit den
landräten hat und sich ganz genau damit
auseinandersetzt was überall im land ist
zumal eben ich ließ daraufhin beide
dicht so und einer gebietskörperschaft
auch die bundesrepublik ist eine
gebietskörperschaft nicht im sinne
dieses gesetzes weil das abstract hier
die länder in allen bezieht aber ein
land ist eine gebietskörperschaft ist
ein klar definierter begriff und ich
muss sagen ich kenne bundes
bundesgesundheitsminister professor
doktor karl lauterbach sehr sehr dankbar
dass er sich zusammen mit den
fraktionsvorsitzenden dagmar schmidt und
dirk wiese und der
gesundheitspolitischen sprecherin heike
während meiner fraktion und mir sehr
stark für diesen begriff und diese
hotspot regelung die ich jetzt noch mal
ausführen durfte
eingesetzt hat
zu der frage zu der frage
aus der unionsfraktion
sie können vielleicht im tenor meiner
rede entnehmen dass ich es gut gefunden
hätte wenn eine masken pflicht weiter
aufrecht erhalten wäre aber wir wir hier
auch eine priorität eine priorität auf
die hotspot regelung die in unglaublich
hohem infektionsgeschehen den ländern
eine größere möglichkeit zum handeln
gibt als nur die masken pflicht
eingesetzt haben und das ist
vielleicht für denjenigen der sich mit
dem argument dann nicht durchsetzt nicht
die schönste stunde der demokratie aber
es ist demokratie genauso wie andere
kollegen vielleicht für die
ausgestaltung dieser hotspot regelung
nicht so eingetreten werden wie wir sind
das ist die natur eines kompromisses und
auch das ergebnis der letzten
bundestagswahl
ich habe geschrieben das wir sehr sehr
stark um diesen kompromiss gerungen
haben unterschiedliche ansätze wurden
hier eingebracht wir müssen
gegebenenfalls nachsteuern wir sind
dankbar dass das auch von allen
koalitionsfraktionen so gesehen wird
jetzt ist es aber wichtig zu handeln
damit die regelung die bestehen nicht
aus laufen und deshalb
appelliere ich auch an die anderen
demokratischen fraktionen hier im haus
nicht einem auslaufen quasi zuzusehen
sondern dieses diesem gesetzesentwurf
zuzustimmen werte
werte kolleginnen und kollegen lassen
sie mich aber mit zwei appellen
schließen erstens auch wenn es im
basisschutz keine flächen deckte flicht
mehr gibt eine maske zu tragen wissen
wir dass masken ein effektives mittel
sind und ich appelliere an das
verantwortungsgefühl und die vernunft
unserer bürgerinnen und bürger in
möglichst vielen situationen sich
solidarisch zu zeigen und weiter die
maske zu tragen ich glaube an diese
vernunft denn am ende wird auch die
übernahme von dieser verantwortung mehr
menschen mehr freiheit geben und
zweitens
sehr geehrte bürgerinnen und bürger sehr
geehrte mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
wenn nicht schon geschehen lassen sie
sich impfen wir haben gute impfstoffe
wir haben wirksame impfstoffe impfen
rettet leben und durch eine höhere
impfquote durch eine baldige möglichst
baldige grundimmunisierung
werden wir einen schnelleren weg aus
dieser schrecklichen kanäle finden
vielen dank
bei mir war das für die
sozialdemokraten ja die länder sollen in
den mods kurze wenn solche gefunden
werden was für abstand 2g und 3g
erlassen können kontakt beschränkung
beispielsweise nicht mehr vorgesehen aus
sicht vieler länder gibt es also mit
diesem abgespeckten maßnahmen-katalog
aus ihrer sicht durchaus
probleme aufmerksam zugehört und ich
muss sagen ich habe selten in diesem
hohen haus eines solchen höhere debatte
erlebt dieses ganze gesetz ist
unbestimmter rechtsbegriff und jede
koalitionsfraktion sieht in diesem
gesetzentwurf was sie selber will eine
einheitliche linie kann ich da gar nicht
erkennen
meine damen und herren aktuell meldet
das robert-koch-institut infolge der
ansteckenden sub variante 2a
593.000 neuinfizierte innerhalb der
letzten 24 stunden das sind 46
1739 mehr neuinfektionen als noch in der
vorwoche eine gute zeit also den freedom
day auszurufen wie es die ampel nun
andré antun will nein leider nicht die
deutsche krankenhausgesellschaft meldet
mit dem stand vom 15 märz 2022 einen
erneuten anstieg der belegungszahlen im
vergleich zur vorwoche nämlich 11,4
prozent dieser anstieg ist nach den
statistiken der dkg vor allem auf den
anstieg der belegungszahlen auf der
normalstation um 12,1 prozent
zurückzuführen wegen der omicron fälle
das alles zeigt dass die pandemie eben
noch nicht überwunden ist und wir
weiterhin vorsichtig sein müssen so
recht hättest der grüne baden
württembergische ministerpräsident
winfried kretschmann ich zitiere aus dem
handelsblatt vom 11 märz grob fahrlässig
wenn die bundesregierung ohne not
wirksame in momente für den notfall aus
der hand gibt
es gäbe jetzt nochmal eine zwischenfrage
wunsch aus der art der fraktur
auf dem euch nicht am unverständlichsten
sind die laxen vorgaben beim tragen
einer fb2 maske warum sind die masken im
einzelhandel beim restaurant oder
barbesuch nicht mehr pflicht wenn zig
studien mittlerweile den hohen
wirkungsgrad der schutzmasken
nachgewiesen haben diese verhältnismäßig
harmlose maßnahme schon jetzt aus der
hand zu geben kommt einer
realitätsverweigerung gleich die
menschenleben gefährdet wie ist mein
grünen-kollege janosch dahmen gegenüber
dem handelsblatt rick kürzlich
richtigerweise gesagt hat dies war auch
die einhellige meinung der experten im
rahmen der sachverständigenanhörung am
vergangenen montag im
gesundheitsausschuss bei dieser anhörung
musste sich die ampel vertreter unter
anderem von der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin anhören dass
die geplanten deutlich
heruntergefahrenen schutzvorkehrungen
auf länder eben deutlich unzureichend
sind zu werden erfordernisse von test
nachweisen sehr eingeschränkt die 3g
regel nur im rahmen der hotspot regelung
für den notfall in aussicht gestellt die
oft sehr schwammigen nicht näher
definierten begriffe geben den ländern
kaum rechtssicherheit ab welcher
schwelle es geht zum beispiel möglich
wäre eine gebietskörperschaft zum
hotspot zu erklären und vielleicht noch
schlimmer mit dem so herunter gekürzten
werk zur kästchen wird es nicht möglich
sein im bedarfsfall schnell und
unmittelbar wirkung der massnahmen
gericht sicher zu erlassen meine damen
und herren das vor dem hintergrund der
situation ist es verantwortungslos die
ampel regierung stellt die weichen dafür
dass der staat seine schutzpflichten
gegenüber der bevölkerung verletzt und
dass wir im herbst 2022 wieder da stehen
wo wir im herbst 2021 gestanden sind das
werden wir als union nicht mitmachen hat
er dagegen lehnen wir diesen
gesetzesentwurf klar vielen dank
stefan kritiker war das für die
unionsfraktion ist mitglied im
gesundheitsausschuss der ja berät über
das über diesen gesetzentwurf zur
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
und wir haben schon mehrfach gehört
heute nachmittag geht es dann direkt
weiter denn das parlamentarische
verfahren ist straff am freitag soll ja
schon endgültig darüber abgestimmt
werden in bundestag und bundesrat
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen bei der
heutigen ausschusssitzung am heutigen
vormittag hat starts erklärt der franken
die situation mit dem wort beschrieben
wir haben ein allzeithoch ein
allzeithoch der inzidenz zahn ein
allzeithoch der belegung der der
hospitalisierung rate ein allzeithoch
der neuen fälle und ein allzeithoch auch
der täglichen toten was meine damen und
herren muss alles noch passieren bis
dann endlich die ampel koalition ihrer
regierungsverantwortung ernst nimmt und
dass vor allen dingen
auch vor dem hintergrund dass wir an
einer stelle die für den tiefgang
allzeithoch haben und das ist die
impfquote aber ich wähle an dieser
stelle die gelegenheit nutzen
fehlerquelle es möchte ich noch jemand
die gelegenheit nutzen hat sich jetzt
erneut von der ard möchten sie die
zwischenfragen danke ich möchte die
gelegenheit nutzen eine wesentliche
fehlerquelle dieses gesetz des vorhabens
zu beschreiben wir haben zu beginn der
legislaturperiode von der ampelkoalition
den hinweis bekommen dass man zukünftig
die korona politik wissenschaft gestützt
durch führen will und dazu den
expertenrat eingerichtet 19 renommierte
experten sollten seit diesem zeitpunkt
die regierung in ihren entscheidungen in
ihren analysen begleiten daraus die
richtigen schlussfolgerungen
für die gesetzesvorhaben ziehen seit
diesem zeitpunkt sind insgesamt acht
experten
stellungnahmen abgefasst worden in denen
die experten bis zur letzten einstimmig
sich für zahlreiche vorgehensweisen
maßnahmen strategien entschieden haben
sie haben sich dafür ausgesprochen sie
haben sie dringend mahnend empfohlen und
nirgendwo haben sie ihm die bisherige
verhaltensweise der regierung eingang
gefunden und die krönung ist jetzt
tatsächlich die situation am vergangenen
montag bei der anhörung die übrigens
ganz zufälligerweise vor der einbringung
stattgefunden hat man hat also auch die
geschäftsführung die geschäftsordnung
nach kräften geboren das mitglied des
expertenrates frau professor mendl
bringt man hat sich entgegen
wahrscheinlich der erwartung der
fragenden in dieser anhörung ganz klar
dafür ausgesprochen dass man instrumente
aufrecht erhalten sollte die bis jetzt
gewirkt haben sie hat sich klar dafür
ausgesprochen dass die jetzige situation
beibehalten werden sollte und insofern
wäre ein gesetzesvorschlag der von der
cdu csu formuliert werden müsste im
grunde genommen einsatz verlängern wir
die jetzige situation die jetzige
regelung um drei monate und dann sind
wir vor den weiteren herausforderungen
der pandemie geschützt und das hat ganz
klar zur folge dass die botschaft nur
lauten kann liebe ampelkoalition
orientieren sie sich an ihren ratgebern
orientieren sie sich am expertenrat
orientieren sie sich an den aussagen in
der anhörung bis freitag haben sie noch
zeit daraus die richtigen schlüsse zu
ziehen für uns ist der klare schluss aus
der anhörung ablehnung dieses
gesetzesvorschlags 480
nicholson sagt dass hierfür die cdu csu
fraktion erst in vertretung
gesundheitsausschuss wir jetzt weiter
beraten werden wird unter anderem eben
über diese gesetzentwurf zur änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes
es ist ein kompromiss das haben wir von
den rednern der ampel koalition hier
während dieser ersten lesung gehört
euphorie klingt anders die fdp hatte
andere vorstellungen als spd und grüne
daraus macht man kein geheimnis und drei
aus gekommen